let's talk about Robin Williams so
obviously that's the the big news this
week
apparently he commits suicide 63 years
old you've heard all about it obviously
so let's just watch some clips this is
not a test
this is rock and roll I know size can be
daunting but don't be afraid I love you
talk about your bad connection
I took LSD I'll be talking to every
blade of grass like sorry sorry sir to
walk into a major league baseball
stadium like Shh
in your face camel cake in your rear
cover here lying crying spying point
also big you Luke rude rude back
appreciate food dude now you asked me if
I've been practicing medicine well if
this means opening your door to those in
need those in pain caring for them
listening to them applying a cold cloth
until a fever breaks if this is
practicing medicine if this is treating
a patient and I am guilty as charged sir
all right a true legend obviously and
just insane talent I mean everything he
did was good so I thought having you two
on for this would be perfect cuz I got
the movie guy and the comedy guy so
let's start with the movie I'm not even
gonna give you a question just give me
something disagree with you right off
the bat we challenged the host
everything he did wasn't good in fact
many of them were very very bad yeah and
you wanna save this for the end what a
start their band no because with that
that the testament to his strength as a
performer is that he had he could I
think he could have made a thousand bad
movies and everyone still loved Robin
Williams it did not his his thing and
his thing was varied you know he could
be very somber and very dark and then
everybody knows how sort of exuberant
and sort of all you know scandalously
over the top he could be it didn't
matter we still love Robin Williams even
if you walked out of a movie
and thought that was a horrible way so
what were some of the bad ones cuz when
I was looking through the list everyone
I kept looking I was like love that love
that love that business granny oh man I
get others day and father's day with
Billy Crystal that was the one that
really sucked I guess because the museum
like the later ones you know the first
one was okay but I mean these are kids
movies they were they weren't serious
but I liked the first night at the
Museum fine yeah but I mean there's a
there's a pretty good list of 10 or 12
movies plus I can you know cancelled
television show the critics didn't were
that guy never saw it yeah so I think
it's a testament to how great a
performer he was that he could perform
in so many different ways live in front
of a crowd as a stand-up in a theater on
television or in movies and the quality
overall quality of the work was
sometimes questionable but but his work
was never really questionable and
whatever this sort of feeling that we
had to care about him
persevered no matter the strength of the
material yeah before we get to the dark
comedian secret that kind of thing do
you think there's ever gonna be a
performer we don't have those guys
anymore the band's talking about the
guys that can do stand-up that can act
in movies you know he was just in a
sitcom it was cancelled but we really
don't have those guys now that buddy
ebsen's gone I don't really think I
think you talk about you you love Robin
Williams even in he's in a bad movie I
mean that's the same like mother Ishtar
I thought he was great in that I thought
here that people didn't like that movie
Beverly Hills Cop with some of his best
work though the thing was weird when he
was in matrix I was like this is gonna
be weird cuz I would be laughing but it
still it worked it worked he played kind
of dumber than he is and the thing that
killed me like his you to mention his
television and I was going nuts when
they cancelled Boston Legal I'm like
that is the best goddamn I mean it
wouldn't Emmys but they didn't care
about the quality right so then they
gave him some shitty show on CBS so what
everybody anyway that I loved all that
stuff you know i watch him and anything
and i didn't think you know people gave
him [ __ ] well he shouldn't be Batman but
I thought he did a great job he was
fantastic that's why I love him he was a
chameleon right he could do anything
yeah he's a very very much like Jack
Nicholson in that way I'm very shocked
how this segment is started we went
immediately
his bad movies and now to the
lesser-known cameos that I had in those
rows no but Tech Poets Society was a big
movie that influenced my life yeah for
real like so when I saw it and I had
only heard you know he was course a hero
to me when he was Mork and Mindy and
then I saw Dead Poets Society and it
woke up something in me like Oh
everything's [ __ ] and that's when I
kind of realized in spoil [ __ ] in the
world and nothing matters and tried to
have some honey drip off your tongue
while you're still alive yeah so and I
don't mean that in a filthy way it
sounded kind of thing yeah well I do go
to honey pots in Marino and that's a
[ __ ] anyway let me tell one amusing
story about Dead Poets Society that
relates not to Robin Williams but to Joe
Biden okay so at TCM we do this thing in
2004 where we talked to politicians
about the movies that influenced their
lives and we get an incredible group
because we get John Edwards John McCain
Joe Biden like three guys who made some
news in the years that followed right
and then Orrin Hatch's
[ __ ] so you had two Democrats two
reports aside right but only because it
was shot in Delaware oh I was like the
first movie shot silent so in talking to
him about it I would say you know what
the message of the movie that you know
that sort of to challenge authority and
question things and believe in yourself
and stand up for what you believe in and
he'd be like yeah that was great
I just remember the scene where they're
running over the hills and that was in
my every question he would answer with
something about Delaware Biden yeah I
mean that really is so bad all right
Jimmy explain the the dark mind of the
comedian because that's what everybody's
talking about these people make
everybody laugh that's what we do but
secretly we're all depressed well you'll
see yes
well we'd like every what do people go
well doesn't a lot of comedy come from
dark yes well that's what you need
comedy for you don't need comedy to
lighten the load of your day at
Disneyland
you need comedy to lighten the load of
the [ __ ] horrible [ __ ] in your life
right you need to talk about he talks
about drug addiction and stuff you know
that's why people can't comedians
constantly talk about their marriages or
their relationships or their work or
whatever it's things that frustrate us
that we need comedic relief from so of
course
was depressed and it seems like you know
like the more depressed you are except
for Jerry Seinfeld seem like the more
messed up you are the better your art is
that seems to be always what it is right
because you feel a need to connect with
people more you need to express yourself
more because you have angst and so he
had them so when people that's kind of
Bobby when they go oh well he was the
you know he's a clown but he's got to
have a dark side everybody has a dark
side we just have also a talent for
comedy
everybody's messed up there are 30,000
or 39,000 suicides a year in America so
it's not you're not all comedians right
they're not all kimete exactly only well
I always think it's funny when they I
think they just juxtapose it because
it's like you how can you be dark and
then also make people oh my god well
it's such a simplistic way of looking at
you says it like Jerry Seinfeld says he
has a you know I remember he was talking
with Garry Shandling Gere saying do you
think that it's because it was screwed
up and and she says no we have a type of
talent they have a talent for comedy how
about I'm a regular person and I have a
talent for this so I just think that you
know I think comedians on a lot of ways
used to call me to get attention I'm
sure that's what he did right like when
I was you know when I met Robin he was
very he didn't really get going until
there were a couple of people in the
room yeah I mean and even and that's
what I noticed anyway firsthand yeah but
I I think that that bothers me when
people say comedians are depressed or
they're darker they're what no we have a
talent we learned how to get attention
being funny which to me is the best gift
you can give somebody if you tell
someone something that makes them laugh
you've just lighten their day you've
made them connected to the moment you're
living in the present so now that
spiritual to me comedy is my
spirituality as a non Jew and I are the
greatest people alive yeah as a non
comedian I'd like to share my thoughts
on that because I think you're bye bye
bye echoing Jerry Seinfeld's point which
is a good point
like that I'm just talented and I'm a
regular person it ignores the fact that
there is something particularly special
about the talent that you have and it's
possible we don't really know that that
talent comes from something else that
there is some other part of you and
doesn't mean that all of you were
depressed it might mean that there's a
28% chance that some of your or more are
darker and I just think that that's
possible it doesn't change what's true
about what he says it does seem based on
100 percent anecdote
evidence that the times that that we
that the regular folks among us run into
comedians in places where they're not on
you often think not that that guy wasn't
funny but that like way that guy was
like it was that guy seemed or that guy
seemed that guy seemed kind of bummed
out like not what you'd expect but but
that also may just be our inability to
process a difference between obviously
you're on stage and you wouldn't meet
Laurence Olivier and be like hey that
guy wasn't that guy acting when we were
having a whiskey at a cocktail party you
know medians are supposed to be
themselves and actors are supposed to be
someone else that's right that's right
that's right
but what comedians are a sliver of who
they are and then you HAMP that up so
the best part of who you are the most
likeable giant charming part of who you
are you'd amp that up on stage so that's
not your whole you can't you don't want
to see you go out there with a belt wait
more quick before we gotta wrap this one
up do you think part of this though is
also that Hollywood kind of I know
that's a broad statement but Hollywood
kind of doesn't know how to deal with
people with that level of talent like
they can sort of deal with people that
have a certain amount of talent a lot of
talent often but he was really off the
charts and maybe that sort of fed into
whatever was going on a lot of really
talented people they don't quite know
what to do with I think I think that
there's some truth to it I certainly
feel misunderstood and we're talking
mostly about people with a lot of talent
I mean I hear you but even a little yeah
even a little don't get it
like you get you thought I was serious
about the ishtar thing that's what I'm
talking about as the kind of [ __ ] I run
into every goddamn day
the thing about Robin Williams was is
that and and we don't know because none
of us knew him well Jimmy met him but
none of us knew him well yeah so like he
seemed unlike some comedians even some
very funny comedians to be incredibly
authentic as funny as Jerry Seinfeld is
I don't feel like I have any insight
into Jerry Seinfeld at all Robin
Williams appeared to make you feel like
you sort of knew Robin Williams uh
therefore it seems incongruous to have a
guy this sad uh look I read one quote
and we'll go so this is what he told
Marc Maron in 2010 talking about the
downside of his career it's trying to
fill a hole and it's fear he told
Marren you're going what am i doing in
my career you bottomed out people say
you have an Academy Award the Academy
Award lasted about a week and then one
week later people are going hey Mork ah
so really yeah I mean that's why I van
Gogh cut is your office so that's all
that's the so that's the thing right so
people think well he had everything well
that's the mistake we make in American
culture and a lot of cultures is that we
think fulfillment is on the other side
of achievement right and then I don't
know if you if you want to achieve a
couple of big things in your life you go
hey that's bunch of [ __ ] I feel
exactly the same and I feel a little
[ __ ] cheated actually I've arrived
but I don't feel any different
I'm exactly myself give me a belt in a
[ __ ] closet door because I want to
kill myself it's almost like you need
the hole to have talent you need that
pain to have talent but then you got to
sort of heal that thing to really talent
itself O'Neil